sean the 90-day universe just keeps
getting
bigger and bigger you're now taking over
the entire
solar system malicia i
look it's obvious you're now hosting the
new talk show
90-day 90-day bears all tell us about it
what can fans expect
when howard lee who is the
head of tlc first came to me about the
show
i was like whoa that's going to be
interesting because this is the space
where we are showing you every single
thing
that we could not show you on regular tv
and when the idea was first presented to
me
it the show was described as
really bears all because there are so
many things
video certain uh confrontations
language body parts
we can't show you on regular tv
but we can show them here bears all
is basically that we are taking
everything and i won't say things that
have been left on the cutting room floor
because
these parts are really juicy but we just
because
of the rules we could not show you there
here we can show you
absolutely everything so bears all
is the perfect title for this show oh
my goodness that's so much it gets me
even more excited
we're gonna take a tour of the set in
just a minute but before we get to that
can you tease any of the conversations
or guests
that we can expect to be on this talk
show for
yes we have a little bit of
everything i can't wait for you to see
the conversation
i had with tariq and his brother dean
if you remember on pillow talk there was
a lot of
chatter online about what happened to
the brothers they were there
one week and then they weren't there
here
we're going to hash everything out these
two
have not spoken for well over
a year but we bring them together for
the very first time
and we hash out everything so
i won't tell you what happens okay but
you gotta tune in
it's going to be very interesting
other than tariq and his brother dean is
there a conversation that you are really
looking forward to having
alicia i cannot wait for you to find out
more about jenny and submit remember
when
submits family came to their home and
told jenny that summit was still married
girl all right so we have a producer who
arrived
there 24 hours later and
what he found out that happened that we
did not air
on regular tv he will be discussing
right here on our bears all stage i've
been wondering
about you know wait wait a minute what
was going on what was going on there
well you'll find out here because i'm
asking him all about it
he knows the behind the scenes details
he knows
more about submits family and what
happened
between them and jenny so i'm going to
be asking him
all of that and i can't wait for you to
find that out yes
it works it's more to what we actually
oh girl
it is so much worse and now i know why
we could not show it on regular tv but
here we can show it
okay also brittany and yazan we knew
from the very beginning that
was a dead end street okay we knew
you're going to see
the the confrontation between britney
and yazan
and his family his family go after
britney
i mean it is so explosive but let me
tell you something
something britney is holding her on he
says that she's got some receipts
that she is gonna show and she does show
them
so it's wild it's so wild are you zan's
parents actually gonna join in on this
conversation or was this behind the
scenes footage yes ma'am
yes ma'am an upset
and that's it this is 90 day bears off
you're going to see different
but familiar faces every single week
that's what's really exciting
one of my favorites angela is going to
do what we call an
ange bush okay you know you ambush
someone
she's going to and bush someone okay and
you gotta wait for that you know
i always tell angela okay now be on your
business behavior but she never does
okay we also have musical performances
you know some of our 90-day
couples are very very talented we've got
big ad
he's joining us so we're going to have
some comedy for sure
comedy big ed is feeling himself and
we have a conversation with david and
annie
that even made me blush i was like what
okay y'all
this is like out of control so you don't
they get to let loose
in a way that they haven't been able to
during the regular season
but also we get to dive in deep with
some
some conversations that are really
really
interesting and so once again it's bears
all
malicious you're going to be like oh my
gosh i can't believe they showed that
but yeah we can show it here you can
show anything
right because and i prepared my mother
for that too i said mom
i'm good okay i'm just telling you right
now
okay okay so speaking of being able to
show everything because it's on a
streaming platform
tell us a little bit about that how fans
can actually tune
into the show and when we can expect the
first episode well the first episode is
launching
january 4th and it's on discovery plus
and this is a companion show to our
90-day series franchise and you will be
able to tune in
every single week and see a new episode
so we've got lots of good stuff girl
every single week
well i'm gonna give it all to you so we
can actually take a look at this
beautiful set i see
first of all as i said we're going to
have guests joining us from all
over the world for those who can't be
here in the studio i'm going to be
talking to them
on this monitor right here now come on
over this way
i love this area because it's really
cozy
we got our pillows here we might uh kick
off our shoes and
lay on the pillows we've got a fireplace
going
over here this area we've got like some
greenery
i love this fiddly fig it's real too i
cannot grow these things at all so i
love this one here
this area we'll be using for some
performances yes
we're going to have a lot a lot of
talented people
here on the 90 day bears all set
so come on over here i love this area
we've got the skyline back here and
look what we have libations
so there's going to be drinks flowing
that's the only way to like loosen them
up
and getting them to really bear all
yeah okay in terms of station
conversation
okay come on over here this is our
amazing crew
get a behind-the-scenes look at all of
our crew here
this is the better view of our set
so we are very very excited can't wait
for you to see it
[Music]